you know that the person who is calmer
is going to win in all those movies it's
the one who can like who's like
incredibly still then swipes with a
sword incredibly quickly and then still
again that's the winner the one who has
a zen state of mind
the line is this imagine how effective
you would be if you weren't anxious all
the time why did you put this out
and
have you seen highly anxious people
become people who
experience very little anxiety is that
something you've seen but first why did
you put this up
what was behind it and then have you
seen anxious people become largely i
guess unanxious or non-anxious people
most of my tweets are not very
deliberate or thought through what's
happening is i've been thinking about
some concept for
you know months years whatever it's been
percolating and then all of a sudden
it'll come to me sort of in like one
spiffy sentence where i'm like oh this
is how i will remember this thing this
is how i can distill this down into a
pointer for myself so that when i need
to make decisions i can retrieve that
whole line of reasoning and so where
this comes from is basically
like everybody after a certain age i am
taking responsibility for my own
happiness and peace and quality of life
and
one of the things you learn after you
make money is that
money doesn't make you happier it takes
care of your money problems but it's not
necessarily going to put you in a place
where you're in some kind of bliss all
the time in fact there's nothing out
there that will make you happy forever
so you sort of have to take
responsibility for guiding yourself
in such a way that your mental state
ends up where you want it and so i've
been working on my mental state and i
have you know working as a big word i
don't i don't want to say i've been
working on it but i would say my mental
state has gotten to a place which is
much better than it used to be
and people will often say well i don't
want to do that because it'll take away
my ambition i want to succeed right now
and so i've thought about that a fair
bit and is that true or not well
certainly for me in the last few years
since i've become calmer my
effectiveness has gone through the roof
and i've been more successful but it's
hard to disambiguate that from well also
maybe you're just later in your career
you're in a better position for it and
that's a valid criticism
so one of the things i've been trying to
figure out is like would i have been as
successful and it's hard to do the
counter factual obviously if i wasn't as
anxious because anxiety is you know
comes from fear it's also a motivator it
makes you get off your butt and one of
the ways to make the anxiety go away at
least until the next piece of anxiety
comes along is to go do something about
it so what is the role of anxiety well
firstly i noted that pretty much
everybody's anxious all the time it's a
rare human being who isn't anxious and
it makes sense we're alpha predators you
know we took over this earth and
domesticated or killed all the other
animals and we did that by being the
most paranoid the most fearful the most
angry predators this world has ever seen
so anxiety is built into the core of who
we are in fact you could argue that all
the mind does all day long is fear-based
scenario planning for survival and then
maybe a little bit of greed for
replication so anxiety is at the core
level of who we are but certainly some
people are more anxious than others
there's no question
and some people seem to be much calmer
about it so which is more useful for
effectiveness so assuming that your goal
is your your motivation is intrinsic
you're doing the thing because you love
it or because you really want it and you
can separate that motivation from
anxiety
then i think you can take on certain
superpowers and we kind of all
intrinsically know this like if you look
at you know samurai warriors right like
miyamoto musashi is in a duel with
somebody else you know that the person
who is calmer is going to win in all
those movies it's the one who can like
who's like incredibly still then swipes
with the sword incredibly quickly and
then still again that's the winner the
one who has a zen state of mind
similarly in the terminator movies part
of the reason you fear the terminator is
because he's a robot he's unstoppable
he's implacable you can't argue with him
you can't communicate with him you can't
make him slow down and he has no remorse
he just keeps coming or in that old
clintuswood movie unforgiven you know
the guy who wins the gunfight is the one
who doesn't flinch he's just keeping his
cool while he's loading his gun and
shooting he's not like all over the
place running around so i just think we
waste so much energy through anxiety
that if you can be calm and still go
about your business it's a superpower
and i i realized this myself recently
where i was in a conflict situation
business it was a high conflict
situation it was unfortunate we i think
we've solved it
but as i went through this high conflict
situation i'd been through one like it
years before where i was much more
anxious and i remember that time period
i remember how much i was sweating it
and how nervous i was and how i went
through bouts of fear and anger and and
how kind of worked up i was the entire
time intense and didn't get much sleep
but this time i was incredibly calm and
i was almost enjoying it because it was
like practicing my craft now of course
it's easier to do now because i have
more money but at the same time
it just didn't bother me it was just
very mechanical and because of that i
could be very effective about it and i
could be effective about it while doing
lots and lots of other things my mind
wasn't constantly spinning in a
whirlpool taking on 10 different
problems and just fear-based scenario
planning all the time
most of these things were never going to
happen so
i do believe that being calm and still
going about your business is the
superpower now yes if anxiety is your
only motivator then you have a problem
but i would argue the pure motivations
don't come out of anxiety so let's talk
about
attribution here to what would you
attribute the and i know this that it's
difficult to isolate variables etc but
if let's just say like you have a family
so let's just say one of your kids comes
to you it's like
dad i'm suffering from a lot of anxiety
what should i do or you observe it and
you want to help your kid out what types
of recommendations would you make or
might you make another question if you
prefer it is what has helped you to go
from
the whirlpool experience of anxiety in
high conflict experience round one
versus calm neval and high conflict
experience round two
yeah it's really hard to separate all
the pieces out i mean it comes from a
combination of
philosophy yoga meditation
getting older having kids you know like
you i've i've had some psychedelic
experiences but those are very far back
in the past just a distant memory at
this point but i would say the number
one thing that has been very very
important for me is meditation and it's
a stupid thing to say because it's so
trite everybody just says it now but
when i say meditation i don't mean
sitting there and watching your breath
or chanting a mantra i mean
self-examination
and meditation is a great way to do that
self-therapy it's sitting there with
your thoughts
so anxiety the anxiety anxiety this this
pervasive non-specific anxiety we were
just constantly on edge about everything
that comes from an unexamined life you
know i think what's the socrates said
like an unexamined life is not worth
living i forget who said that quote
something like that yeah but it's it's
not all soccer too one of those one of
those smart philosopher types but it's
correct it's your unexamined life that
is causing the problems and you can
examine it in multiple ways you can
examine it through you can have some
crazy mushroom trip where it all comes
out one night you could do a lot of
meditation sitting there with yourself
and letting your mind run crazy and then
seeing what's actually in your mind that
your mind wants to tell you and have you
listened to and have you resolved that
is unresolved it could be through
therapy
it could be through reading lots of
philosophy and reflection and long walks
so there's many many ways to tackle it
but it's that spending that time with
yourself to examine why are you having
these thoughts think about it this way
we spend so much time in our
relationships our relationship with our
wives our relationship with our
colleagues our relations to our business
partners our relations with our friends
the most important relationship you have
is with yourself it's with this voice in
your head that is constantly rattling
every waking hour it's this crazy
roommate living inside your mind who's
always chattering always chattering
never shuts up and you can't control
these thoughts they just come up out of
you don't even know where
that quality of those quality of your
thoughts
those conversations you're having in
your head all the time that is your
world that is the world you live in
those that's the world view you have
that's the lenses you see through and
that's going to determine the quality of
your life more than anything else and if
you want to see what the quality of your
life actually is put down the drink put
down the computer put down the
smartphone put down the book put down
the headphones
just sit by yourself doing nothing and
then you will know what the quality of
your life actually is because that's
what you're always running away from
that's why people when they try to
meditate to sit down like i hate it i
can't sit still why because your mind is
eating you live your life is unexamined
your mind is running in loops over
things that it has not resolved and
because they're not resolved when you
run around in your normal life it's not
those problems have gone away it's that
they're just there they're there and but
they're provoking anxiety and what you
think of as the anxiety that's that's
kind of consuming you and you can't
identify the source that's just the tip
of an iceberg poking out from underneath
the water and underneath this giant pile
of garbage of decisions that were made
without too much thought of situations
that you're in that you haven't resolved
that you need to resolve of problems
that you have or desires that you have
that have gone unmet or unmanifested or
contradictions that you're living in or
ways that you which you feel trapped so
proper meditation proper examination
should
ruin the life that you're currently
living it should cause you to leave
relationships it should cause you to
re-establish boundaries with family
members with colleagues it should cause
you to quit your job it should cause you
to change your eating patterns it should
cause you to spend more time with
yourself it should cause you to change
what books you read it should cause you
to change who your friends are if it
doesn't do that it's not real
examination if it doesn't come attached
with destruction of your current life
then you can't create the new life in
which you will not have the anxiety or
at least parts of it not necessarily
whole cloth so let's ask
let's let's dive into meditation because
as you mentioned it's a term that is
used a lot and in the minds of most
it is represented by things that you
just said
you do not do like the mantra based
meditation or following the breath
and you and i have meditated before i
don't know if your approach is still
similar but it is
quite a
i hate to talk about trite paradigm
shift in a sense
at least in the way that i experienced
it alongside you at one point which was
literally
doing
nothing for extended periods of time i
don't know if that's still the case but
could you
describe the practice a bit because it's
it was such a burden lifted
in a sense
when the pass fail is removed
and
the experience that i had after say a
week of doing this twice a day which is
not necessarily what people do in normal
life but it was pretty profound so could
you describe
the current practice which may be
different from what i experienced
yeah i actually have two different
things that i do and i almost hate
calling it meditation because everyone
has in their mind a preconceived notion
of what meditation is let's not even
call it that i would say that there are
two self-examination practices that i do
and i don't even call them practices
anymore because sometimes i do them
because i feel like them and i enjoy
them or because it feels right and
sometimes i don't because anything done
routinely sort of becomes its own trap
and it's not going to get you anywhere
it just becomes like another spiritual
high another checkbox right now is it
fair though to say that you're able to
opt in and out now because you had a
certain front loading period of doing it
consistently actually i'll say there are
three different things that i do and
i'll go through them the first is i just
read a lot of philosophy especially at
night time before i go to bed which ones
schopenhauer maxims who are we talking
about yeah schopenhauer western
philosophy is my current favorite uh
although i've definitely moved around on
that one eastern philosophy i'll read
everything from osho i know he's
discredited and been canceled but
fantastic that makes me like him even
more
krishnamurti i don't know kapil gupta uh
rupert spira i mean it's all over the
place uh anthony demelo he's fantastic
actually i'm gonna start with one book
start with anthony demelo's way to love
um or his book awareness they're both
really good
but there's a ton of them i basically
read a lot of philosophers siddhartha
vasis says yoga bhagavad gita the dao de
chang you know i'm always going through
one of these books at any given time and
usually rereading for inspiration and
i'll read these at night usually
there'll be one or two things i'll catch
on to it'll i'll reflect on it before i
go to sleep so that is a form of
self-examination and it's it's not done
because it's a formula it's done because
i'm genuinely interested in these things
so it's not work to me it's fun the
second thing that i do is which i've
been doing for a long time now is
just trying to be aware of my thoughts
and not in a you know sit there and be
like oh i'm gonna be aware of my
thoughts kind of way but just realizing
that a lot of these thoughts that come
up aren't unbidden i don't control them
it's not like i decided to have this
thought i don't even know what i'm
saying to you right now it's coming out
of my mouth at the same time as i'm
thinking it so where is this coming from
who is this person what is this person
saying is this true is it correct has it
been correct in the past uh is he just
being paranoid now is he being crazy
what are his underlying motivations and
i'm not even questioning so much but
more just kind of seeing it and after a
while when you see it you start seeing
through your own bs you start seeing how
you're mainly just justifying whatever
the heck you want to believe because
it's good for your survival it's good
for your replication or it's good for
your money or it's going to get you late
or any of these various things and when
you're doing that reflection is it
sitting at a table pen and paper is it
no no
half lotus with your eyes closed what is
this no it's literally just walking
around it's just walking around it's
nice
it's just life just just if you say
something to me i'm always going to
listen to it with a slightly critical
filter because you're external to me
applying that same filter to my own
thoughts gives me a level of peace and
distance from them and the ability to
see through my own bs which i think
makes my life better so i've just found
that to be a useful thing way of life
but there are lots of times where i
forget to do it i get caught up in some
emotions some runaway train of thought
but usually these days i can catch
myself and be like okay i'm in that
mindset again i'm having that mode of
reactions again and when the mind sort
of sees me chattering it quiets down a
bit right and like i said that go back
to that crazy roommate analogy which i
originally picked up from michael singer
by the way he has a good book called the
untethered soul
but you know the room the crazy roommate
analogy like you would eventually tell
your roommate to shut up or you would
tell them to start justifying their
claims or you would at least at some
level you start dismissing them for just
kind of rambling all the time in this
fear paranoic mode so i think just kind
of viewing your thoughts as sort of
these unbidden things that arise from
within you but aren't really necessarily
the whole story and should be viewed
with the same level of skepticism that
you would apply to an outside observer i
think that frame work is helpful and if
you find it to be true then you'll find
yourself doing it more often if you find
it not to be true if you're like no
actually i choose these thoughts and i
want to have them and that's who i am
and this all makes sense to me then you
can stop viewing it with a critical eye
that's up to you but the last one is the
one that i think people think of as more
traditionally meditation which is
sitting down and meditating and on that
one i learned from an indian gentleman
same same character you learned from who
i had a very simple system and i just
found it the most compelling form of
meditation i've ever tried which is you
sit there for 60 minutes so
unfortunately not less than an hour at a
time because it takes 30 to 40 minutes
to sink in past the initial chattering
so you get to the good part or the
so-called runner's high equivalent
um and you sit for 60 minutes every day
and you do it for at least 60 days and
you do it first thing in the morning
it's been your mind is clear and you're
alert and you've had a good night's
sleep and you sit up with your back
straight and you can use cushions or you
can use a chair or whatever there's no
magic position
and just whatever happens happens
whatever your mind wants to do you just
let it do if it wants to talk you let it
talk if you wants to fight you let it
fight wants to be quiet you let it be
quiet if it wants to chant a mantra or
pay attention to breathing you can do
that but you don't force anything you
just kind of let it happen
and so you don't fight it you don't
resist it you don't argue with it you
don't double down on it
we just kind of let things happen and
when you do that for at least 60 days my
experience has been that you kind of
clear out your mental inbox and all the
craziness that was going on all the
chattering will come out some problems
will get resolved you will have some
epiphanies you will make changes to your
life some will be self-examination some
of you just get tired of some of it just
needs to be heard once and then it goes
away and eventually you'll get to a
mental state of inbox zero where now
you're just thinking about what happened
yesterday you're kind of caught up and
your mind is relatively clear and just
your anxiety level goes down you're
living more peacefully and i've been
doing this for about two and a half
years now and i probably missed about a
dozen days total and but there are some
days where i'm done two hours a day or
more and i will tell you that is the
single most important thing that i do it
is a sheer joy
much of it is highly entertaining
pleasurable sometimes it's just flat
it's nothingness i can't even tell you
why i do it i can't even tell you what's
going on in that state but i will tell
you that that time spent by myself is
the most important time that i have and
thanks to that i am now much more
self-contained i don't feel like i need
other people i don't need external
sources of pleasure or happiness all the
time i drink less i'm not attracted to
trying any drugs whatsoever it's just
life is easier it's more pleasant i
don't take things as seriously i'm not
afraid of my mortality as much anymore i
don't fear aging i don't i don't lust
after things i don't have this constant
pervasive need to find something outside
of me to make my life better when the
best hour of my day is spent by myself
then the world has very little to offer
me and i can still participate in it but
it doesn't have that grip on me that it
used to i don't fear solitary
confinement and i think that is a
superpower and i think everyone should
have it everyone does have it it's easy
it requires doing nothing it's your
birthright you can't fail at it there's
no there's no way to fail at it
literally all you have to do is just sit
down and close your eyes and just just
be by give yourself a break for an hour
every day just take the time off from
the world a few
follow-ups
krishnamurti do you have any any
favorites of his or anything that you
would suggest someone start with if they
have no familiarity with krishnamurti
and i'll second anthony demelo also yeah
i actually remember starting with
christian woody he's a tough one but if
you're gonna start somewhere i started
with this book called think on these
things
there's also the book of life
he's very cerebral very intellectual and
a little confusing
but he definitely speaks truth and he
walks the walk anthony de mello the way
to love osho's book the great challenge
uh and i know people think osho's a fake
guru and all that but he had some real
stuff too he's very articulate he uh he
understood a lot
there's a great clip from him on
soundcloud that says it's called life
has no goals no purpose
i listen to that that one a lot
there's a lot of them out there once you
start going down this rabbit hole you'll
find them the classics the bhagavad-gita
get a good translation stephen miller i
think has a good translation uh he also
has a good translation of the
daodaiching those are both really
interesting
again only if it appeals to you i mean
there's ancient wisdom in schopenhauer
read councils and maxims you know these
are smart people self-reflecting but
overall the point is not to read the
point is to inspire so that you yourself
can reflect in kappa gupta is an account
on twitter he has a couple of great
books direct truth is a fantastic book
um you know written very recently and
pulls no punches
um but you know all of these are
basically there to inspire you to
self-reflect and if you're not
interested in self-reflection if you're
not at that stage in life then don't do
it it's a waste of time
in fact i would say the reason to do
these things is just because they make
your life better because they make you
more effective because they have some
utility to you if they do not have
utility to you if they don't make your
life better then drop it it's useless i
will also
second the reading of philosophy and
this is not
for
kind of idle or abstract
like semantic tail chasing right it's
it's
for whatever reason on a very pragmatic
level deeply soothing
to
read
the insights and observations of those
who are considering things that are not
of today they're not of this week
they're not of this month they are for
much broader periods of time or timeless
in some capacity right it alleviates
some of the manufactured emergency
and urgency of the [ __ ] that is
forced it upon us by every possible
input oh yeah the news and twitter are
so toxic the human brain is not
designed to manage every emergency in
the world in real time we're not
designed to process all the breaking
news on the planet in our heads and this
is one of my recent tweets but the goal
of the media these days is to make every
problem your problem that's how they get
attention that's how they get clicks you
know you have tribal wars going on
zombies battling each other and they
want to pull you in where even
non-participation is not allowed anymore
neutral bystanders are not allowed so
it's it's a crazy world out there
there's a circus going on with the
monkeys flinging feces at each other and
they want to drag you into the fight
really what you want to focus on is
what's timeless timeless is great you
know the the old questions all have old
answers
and they're best consumed from the old
practitioners because they were very
clear-minded about it they weren't busy
trying to fit into the politics of this
time they were fitting to the politics
of that time but that's lost to us now
so actually another great source is i
have your dao seneca series in audible
uh and i listen to it on repeat when i'm
working out a lot so that's a very
kidding
those letters to lucillius uh amazing
yeah amazing stuff and every time i go
through it i learned something new
yeah the telesenica the the moral
letters to leukillus if people want to
look on
public domain from on public domain
sources you can find these letters the
moral letters to leukillus also spelled
as you might read lucillus
by seneca and so that's an audiobook
series that that i produced and you can
find the pdfs for free online as well
[Music]
[Music]
you